تستفيق المانيا الدوله الديمقراطيه على
خبر عمليه دعم واسعه نفذها نحو ثلاثه الاف
من افراد واحده النخبه في جهاز مكافحه
الارهاب عبر 11 ولايه المانيه الهدف
المعلن وفق الادعاء الالماني اعضاء في
حركه مواطن الراعيه كانوا يخططون لاقتحام
البرلمان والاستلاء على السلطه وتنفيذ
هجمات المسلحه على مؤسسه تشريعيه اخرى
نقطه انطلاق تحقيقات كانت صله بين اعضاء
الحركه واعضاء مجموعه وطنيون المتحدون
الذين اعتقلوا في ابريل الماضي على خلفيه
التخطيط لاختطاف وزير الصحه
الالمانيات القرن الماضي وبلغ عدد مؤيدها
عام 2020 نحو 19
وفقا لمسؤولي لاستخبارات الالمانيه حدد
نحو 950 من بينهم على انهم من اقصى يمين
ولد ما لا يقل عن 1000 منهم ترخيص من
امتلاك اسلحه الناريه
يتركز اعضاء الحركه في الجزء الجنوبي
والشرقي من المانيا وبدات الاستخبارات
الداخليه بتتبعهم بعد واقعه قتل عضو منتمي
للحركه لضابط الالماني عام 2016
وتم الكشف عن انتشار منتمينا للحركه في
اوساط الشرطه الالمانيه مما دفع سلطات
الست ولايات لفتح تحقيق مع افراد في
شرطتها بتهمه الارتباط بحركه يمنيه متطرفه
على حركتهم اسماء عديده منها مواطن
الامبراطوريه الالمانيه وحكومه الرايخ
والاشخاص الطبيعيون واعضاؤها لا يعترفون
بدوله الالمانيه الحديثه ولا بقوانينها
ويمتنعون عن دفع الضرائب والمخصصات
الاجتماعيه ويسر لنا على ان الامبراطوريه
الالمانيه لا تزال قائمه حسب البيانات فان
الهيئه المركزيه للحركه يطلق عليها اسم
المجلس وشكدت على غرار مجلس الوزراء في
الحكومه النظاميه اي تتضمن وزاره
العدل والخارجيه والصحه وفق المدعي العام
الالماني اعضاء المجلس يجتمعون بانتظام
منذ نوفمبر 20 الثاني 2021 واسسوا تراعد
عسكريه تهدف الى القضاء على دوله القانون
والديمقراطيه على مستوى البلديات
والمقاطعات وقبل اربعه اشهر حذرت
المخابرات الالمانيه من ان البلاد ينتظرها
مواصفات الغضب بسبب تنام المد اليمني
المتطررف واستغلاله حاله الغضب العامه
بسبب تبعات الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه ودعم
برلين
القارئ انه لا يمكن الحديث عن اي تدخل
الروسي في تحضير الانقلاب في المانيا
معتبرا العمليه الامنيه ضد حركه مواطن
الرايخ شئنا داخليا المانيا